[Music]
my guest tonight is a hilarious stand-up
comedian you know whereas Donna from
NBC's Parks and Rec
please welcome everybody read out what
they are
I like couches couches are nice yeah
says you think I like a chef lounge
I think a chaise lounge
says much beautiful say hard on a bag of
surprises you got any liberian parents
is that right Liberian uh-huh what's a
Liberian accent family um be how you
doin P you good you feeling good you
look good oh you look nice that's the
people in Liberia sound like I'm going
right have you been
I have you have yeah I was there when I
was very like three months old got the
mumps while I was there and then I went
again I was there for first rate it is
big did somebody from the Liberian
travel board like we just got over the
big bump scare they have more than
months but I got over them while I was
there as well
okay so Liberia cures the moment if you
have the mumps go to Liberia ride it out
yes I don't want to mess it out you sang
opera um I'm not good I'm not great I
can sing it you know
you
[Music]